what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
tommy lauren's retraction you guys saw
me react to like her initial video of
like i hate men
now i'm gonna watch her apparently
allegedly
so i've been told like take a step back
before i start don't forget to like
comment and subscribe
i'm trying to get to 15 000 subscribers
this week so
if you want to do me a solid and hit
that subscribe button
that would be cool okay let me make sure
the sound is working
chatter yeah it is okay
that's 16 minutes long
gosh who's got the time
except i guess me right
i don't care what anyone says she's so
pretty
what's up guys
oh waiting for you all to just
join on in here
some of you i probably will answer some
questions uh later on
but i have some things i need to go
through first
all right so she's already like i
messed up i could tell those of you the
other nights i believe it was monday
night who watched my
psa for boyish men um it has since
gained
a little bit of traction i also posted
it on facebook
i think it's sitting at about 1.5
million views right now so
obviously it picked up a little bit of
talk
a little bit of chatter a few haters
which is okay not like i'm not used to
that i'm very used to it true i truly
hear a few things up about that video
and just expand on it a little bit
because
that's always important you can't ever
say everything you want to say
in 15 minutes and i've heard a lot of
comments on it
a lot of praise a lot of criticism so i
figured i'd just go through some of them
if y'all are ready
all right so first of all the some of
the the misperceptions
and misconceptions about some of the
things i said in that video
that i want to go through real quick
first and foremost
okay i don't think all men
are trash and i also want to again
reiterate the distinction that i made
between boys and men there is a big
difference
between boys and men and i'm talking
about an age difference i'm talking
about a mentality difference
if you are a man and you watch that and
you thought that i was calling you trash
i will apologize for that because i
don't think all men are trash i don't
think any
men are trash at all i think that some
boys who think that they are men
have a tendency shall we say
in 2020 this is not the
best start to the apology but i'll i'll
keep listening
to not quite act the right way i'm not
saying that girls act the right way
mind you okay this is an equal
opportunity situation here
but i'm not a dude in case you haven't
noticed i don't identify as a dude i'm
not a dude
so for me to do a video about how crappy
women are in the dating scene
i really don't think i could offer you
that much knowledge on it because i've
never dated a girl
yet okay so i can't
yeah is there is there something you're
trying to tell us help you there
i'm not saying the girls are perfect and
men are awful or boys are awful i'm not
saying that never would say that i'm
sure that there are many horrible girls
out there that do many horrible things i
myself am not perfect
i acknowledge that i'm happy to
acknowledge it so
i wanted to clear that up men i don't
think you're trash i happen to quite
like men
and especially real men who act like men
and who treat women the right way and
i'm going to get into that in a little
bit but
i just have a hard time believing like
i know she's like kind of aggressive i
give her that
but she's very pretty like she's in
shape
you know she could probably be nicer
i'll give her that i just have a heart
but like some guys are really into
conservative women
so i have a hard time believing that
like there are no
nice guys that want to take her out i
want to clear up some other
misperceptions about the video things
that maybe you guys were confused about
so i can help you out it was not in any
way
shape or form about my ex-fiance okay
my ex-fiance is a saint my ex-fiance is
a great individual
a great man and the woman that ends up
with him is going to be incredibly lucky
because all the things that i bitched
about in that video
he didn't do any of those things he's
like why'd you guys break up
great guy so i want to clear that up
she's sad
she i could see it in her eyes she's sad
it wasn't me being scorned about a
broken off engagement
it wasn't me being scorned about a bad
breakup i haven't dated anybody
in months so it wasn't about that and it
was about my ex-fiance so i want to
clear that up
if he's watching or his friends are
watching not about him
another thing that i thought was kind of
weird
because i read some media headlines
about it was that my video the other
night was
homophobic you're gonna have to explain
that to me how that video was homophobic
i don't think it was homophobic in the
least
i can't even wrap my mind around how
anyone say it was homophobic
that makes no sense to me so if anybody
got that impression
um maybe re-watch it because it
certainly wasn't homophobic
but i also want to agree a little bit
about a couple like it wasn't
homophobic all the time at all that i
got and once again
kind of just reinforcing my point here
so the kind of responses that i got from
at least people that i know
males that i know were were two
first of all most of the guys in my life
they either thought it was about them
and it wasn't and they apologized and i
didn't need to
or i had friends of mine that i've never
dated who are just dudes
who messaged me and said hey this
actually really helped me out
because it's a jungle out there and
sometimes men don't know how to act they
don't know what women want
they don't understand what they're doing
wrong
why don't you date one of them like if
all these guys are so bad she has these
guys as friends which was the whole
point of my video
it wasn't to give men a guideline of
things they already knew
it was to help you out in case there's
some things you didn't okay
maybe men don't know that we like plans
to be made maybe men don't know that
consistency
i will say i don't think guys all the
time
are as like like i've had a lot of
friends with long-term boyfriends that
will complain about this about guys not
like their boyfriends or whatever not
setting up dates
is important maybe men don't know that
it's nice to be valued for what you
bring to the table
maybe some men don't know those things
maybe they don't know how important
communication is
men and women think differently totally
understand that so i got a lot of men
that i know
who are great guys who honestly messaged
me and said hey this is helpful
it's nice to know how women think it's
nice to know how you and your friends
think i like you i think you're a cool
chick so
it was great pointers and that again
reinforces my point
that is the difference between a man and
a boy
the men in my life that i've dated met
gone out with or i'm just friends with
they were really
either laughed i thought it was funny or
they were like hey cool thanks for the
heads up
i'm just confused why don't you date any
of them
okay that's a man and then
i got the other responses from boys and
i don't know a whole lot of boys by the
way
but there were some boys that like to
creep through twitter
some with blue check marks some that are
in bum f wherever
and don't whatever that just wanted to
make a comment
um and their responses were tommy
is bashing men tommy hates men
we're not your fan anymore because you
hate men that is a boy response
because a true man would know that the
things that i said probably didn't apply
to them
and if they if some of those things did
apply to them they were like hey
let me make it better so if men want to
make a video and be like hey girls this
is what i think you're doing wrong
kevin samuels i know where you can find
one
ah why am i cracking myself up right now
by all means please do it i will be a
viewer
all right just throwing that out there
but yes so to all those
especially on twitter because twitter is
the most vile place
um that had to have something to say
about how oh
she's not a conservative she critiqued
men she's a feminist i'm not a feminist
and being a feminist is a completely
different thing from what i did
if i'm going to point out and criticize
some of the behaviors of modern men
that does not make me a feminist in fact
i think it makes me pretty damn
conservative
because i'm looking at the way men are
raised right now i'm looking at the way
society is raising men the way pop
culture is raising men
and i'm saying maybe there's a problem i
mean
i know what she's saying she's talking
about like beta males
however i would imagine if all these
like
men in her life are like saying this
stuff to her why don't
you date them a little confusing
all right oh my god this goes on for
another seven minutes
only because i love you guys only
because i love you guys it's a very
conservative thing to say
and i'm gonna get to a little bit more
of that in a little bit as well
but i also want to talk about the
responses that i got from women and
most of them conservative women so to
all you boys out there who are telling
me that i'm not a conservative because i
made a critique
of the way modern men act yeah you
should know that all the girls in my dm
are mostly all conservative women and
they all were saying preach
preach preach what you said is true oh
my goodness
thank gosh someone said something
because what you said is true so those
are conservative women out there so for
you so-called conservative men
who are actually some of you boys um who
are saying that
you can't possibly be a conservative and
say anything bad
about the male species in general i'm
sorry you're wrong
i can say whatever the hell i want to
and if those of you
doesn't mean you should who aren't
familiar with me
i really don't care if me speaking the
truth and me
speaking my mind bothers and triggers
people
on the left the right the middle i don't
care i'm going to say what i need to say
and that's what makes me genuine and
real and for those of you that follow me
for a long time you know that about me
that's also probably why guys aren't
trying to date you i mean
i'm she's beautiful i'm sure a lot of
guys try to date her
but i could see why that would be like
like i've heard a lot of women say like
the thing that makes them like
successful in their career
is the thing that can make them
unsuccessful in relationships
so but i don't know i kind of understand
what she's saying
however like a lot of the times when
women
say stuff like that they don't realize
that they're going for like the wrong
type of guy
i'm gonna spit it to you straight
whether i'm doing it on instagram live
or i'm sitting at a bar doing it
all right i'm going to give it to you
straight and that's the way it is it's
not me being bitter
it's not me being mad it's just me
giving you my damn final thoughts
because that is what i do
and i think i'm pretty good at it by the
way so a lot of women
came to me in my dms and like thank you
for saying something so again
i just hope this can be a learning tool
i don't know everything about everything
but
you know at 27 almost 28 years old i
have been around
men i've been around a lot of millennial
men and i've seen some things that i
think could be changed for the better
communication that could be improved
things can be improved upon it would
make us all just a little happier all
right
and men is gonna help you out too
because you're gonna get a real kick-ass
woman
who is going to be really appreciative
of all those things that you fix because
they're probably really simple fixes
someone talk about that um i also want
to talk a little bit about my back
story all right see i agree
with her on some level i think women
really appreciate
i can't remember exactly what she said
in the last video but like
the planning dates and like all that
stuff women really appreciate it
what i was saying is that doesn't mean
you should necessarily rule out a guy
just because
he like texted you the day of to set up
a date like that's not the end of the
world
what but i i hear what she's saying you
know what i mean
again my video tonight was not about my
ex-fiance but prior to
him i dated a lot of just really
horrible men
all right if you guys wrote my book you
know every guy i've ever dated has
cheated on me every guy i've ever dated
has lied to me
every guy i've ever dated has just quite
frankly not been great with a few with a
few exceptions that were great people
but we just didn't work out but most of
the guys have treated me like absolute
crap
and like most of the women watching this
i put up with that for
years okay i in high school through
almost all through college dated the
same guy
who treated me horribly he cheated on me
multiple times
he said horrible things to me he did
horrible things to me and i sat there
and i put up with it i was always
incredibly strong
in my politics i was always incredibly
strong in school in my professional life
in my career and my determination but
for some reason
i went through so many years of letting
someone treat me like crap
and i stayed and i know that there are
so many strong women out there that can
relate to that
because they're such bad asses but when
it comes to men for some reason
they just can't get themselves to be as
strong as they are in other places
well did you know that when you are in a
relationship your brain literally looks
like it's on drugs
so that's why you act crazy because your
brain is like
high on like i don't know the science
behind it but i'm like
there's a therapist that like told me
that once
um but
i mean i think that's really common as i
said the one
downside this is what men don't
understand men
always think that women are like trying
to get the highest like
quality guy which you know anyone's
always trying to get the highest quality
partner
but what men don't understand about
women is when you start dating you're
like
16. and men fall in love with what they
see and women fall in love with what
they hear
so i mean i was i was a little later i
wasn't 16. i was like 19
18. but like
and you're just naive honestly like if
you didn't grow up in an environment
where like
you had a dad that would like tell you
how guys can be and like tell you that
like
guys like this like that guy's full [ __ ]
that guy's full [ __ ] like
you kind of act like an idiot because
you have to think about your brain is
literally on drugs
literally i once i got out of that long
relationship
i fixed the hell out of that and then
after that
i decided i wasn't gonna put up with it
anymore and
i had a few bumps in the road along the
way but pretty much so
i haven't put up with a lot since then
and i hope that all you women out there
will be the same way and men
if you guys are with a horrible girl or
a horrible woman and she doesn't treat
you well
i hope you'll do the same and i think
this happens a lot like
women a woman will have a bad experience
with a guy and like this totally
happened to me where i like it was just
a really bad experience
and then they'll start to hate men and
like blame
men but you start to realize
like as you get older that maybe you
were
um looking for the wrong things if that
makes sense like
you might have cared about something
superficial instead of like
common values common interests and i so
i hate it when guys will say like
women settle because that's not true you
just
look for someone that has qualities that
you could raise a child
with um however what i've seen is that
after like a bad relationship
women will raise their standards like
crazy like crazy high and say i'm not
gonna put up with anything
and you have to remember that men are
human like they're human beings they
make mistakes just like women make
mistakes
there's reasons they could write you off
too you know so
it's it's a hard balance dating is not
easy and there's no
like simple
like right answer in dating i hope
you'll be strong enough to say peace
because no one deserves to be treated
like crap all right
and there are some things that just
aren't fixable in a relationship if it's
gone on and gone on and gone
on and the precedent has been set for
treating each other like crap
in my personal experience it probably
just isn't ever gonna work people don't
change that much when they've been set
in their ways and the precedent has been
set
and here's another thing for ladies out
there if i would give you a little bit
of advice is you teach people how to
treat you which is actually part of the
point of the psa that i did the other
night
you set your own price tag you teach
people how to treat you set the
precedent
if you say this is what i expect then
those people that want to meet those
expectations they'll still be there
all right so i just want to give you
that unless
okay i will say that's a lot easier for
her to say
as a girl who's like extremely
attractive like
i mean you guys i i already know half of
you have come from kevin samuels
so you're gonna say that she's like an
adjustable six whatever but like
i'm sorry but if i go out into the
street 2021 i see 10 people
she's probably more attractive than nine
of them i'm not in miami i'm not in like
some crazy attractive like city i'm just
in the suburbs
just my two cents that piece of advice
um
i also want to talk about what i call
the dbap
double standard for those of you who
follow clay travis and a lot of
others they've developed that term dbap
don't be a
i think you know what the p word stands
for i'm not going to say it but it's
funny to me that i got ripped up and
down by
conservative accounts on twitter because
i basically said
don't be a and all of a sudden i'm
bashing men
but when a man says d-bap
there every man goes yeah yeah don't be
a okay
so i'm confused um i don't like double
standards i'm not a feminist but you
guys know i'm gonna call it a double
standard when i see it
so for me to say d-bap to the men out
there who are acting like
you know what all right that's not me
bashing men that's me doing the same
thing that a lot of other men do
to men saying hey grow up act right
be a man okay just gonna throw that out
there
be a man treat women with respect and
also demand that respect in return
you gotta make sure women treat you
right as well you don't and that's
that's true like there's a lot of girls
from what i've seen okay i don't know
any uh like
any girls that have the standards that
these
okay maybe one or two but i don't know
many girls that have the standards
like that i see in like kevin samuels
and a lot of these other shows but from
what i've been seeing like
it's not easy for men either honestly i
want a sugar baby
you don't want a girl that's dm in five
different guys you don't want a girl
that's got nothing going on who relies
on you for everything
hell no hell no that's why i'm trying to
help you find a girl that brings
something to the table
hell find a girl that brings a table to
the table i think it's gonna work out
better for you i hope that for you i
hope that for me dammit i hope i can
find a guy that appreciates the fact
that i bring a table to a table all
right
and that's another thing i'm not perfect
for people that thought that my
my commentary that i did the other night
was me just being self-indulgent
guys i laugh at myself more than anybody
else out there i know i got
problems i am in many cases i'm a damn
dumpster fire when it comes to
relationships and everything else
i am not perfect i am also a mess
okay but i do get frustrated just like
anybody else and for those people that
tell me well you should just stick to
politics and talking about politics
i hate to inform you of this but i'm a
whole damn human i'm a whole
damn human with many dimensions i talk
about a lot of things
all right i don't just stick to politics
because i'm a living breathing human
that has opinions about a lot of things
okay
that's just me that i guess that's the
benefit of me um my mouth
and also the disadvantage of me my mouth
sorry
the way it is that's how i am but that's
what i was saying like the same thing
that makes her successful in politics
probably makes her unsuccessful in
relationships
sorry if you don't like it bye
but um another thing i want to talk
about too is no
woman wants perfection i know a lot of
you guys are saying oh
nobody's perfect we try that's all we're
asking for
for me in a relationship i just ask for
a couple of things i ask for you to be
authentic
and i ask for you to be loyal and that
to me comes with a side of good
communication
and that's what i'm saying like girls
hit a certain age they just get tired
they get tired they just want the guy
that won't hurt them being direct
i'm very direct i don't beat around the
bush i tell people how i feel
i tell people what i'm thinking and if
they like it or not
that is the way it is i personally like
to know where i stand with people
which is why i am very direct i think
the worst feeling for a man
for a woman is not knowing where you
stand with somebody i think that's the
most frustrating thing
i don't have time the older i get the
more
i've realized that most people won't
tell you to your face
and the more time i've spent on the
internet i'm for it i don't have time
for the games
i don't like to be texting somebody and
then they just stop
texting me or they fade out for a few
days you know if you're interested stay
interested
and if you're not interested anymore
then fine but please don't circle back i
talked about this the other night that's
just really the big thing for me is just
be direct
in your communication if you're not
feeling me then just please just go away
it's just that simple go away but don't
come back but
this is a lesson a lot of girls have to
learn the guys that circle back
aren't really like interested in you so
you should probably just cut them off
like if you don't respond it's not even
like
it's not it doesn't bother you like you
don't have to respond
anyway just my two cents um i don't
think she's absolutely crazy i agree
with some of the stuff she said
however if she keeps her standards
like crazy high to the point that if a
guy doesn't respond for two days
he's dead to her like
sorry it sounds like i just contradicted
myself
but it all depends on how like
i don't know how to put it like tight
she is like i don't really know how she
dates
but i don't know just my two cents i'm
getting tired
okay don't forget to like comment and
subscribe